sabemos que para x en el intervalo
abierto menos un medio un medio esta
expresión menos 2 entre 12 x es igual a
esta serie de aquí y después nos dicen
usando este hecho encuentra la función
correspondiente a la siguiente serie y
como siempre ponle pausa este vídeo e
intentar resolverlo por tu cuenta
bueno lo primero que podemos pensar es
oye cómo sabemos que esta expresión es
igual a esta serie y entonces tal vez en
estos momentos empiezas a reconocer que
esta es una serie geométrica donde el
primer término es menos 2 y después
multiplicamos cada término por la razón
común para obtener el siguiente término
y en este caso la razón común es 2x aquí
también estamos multiplicando por dos
equis y así nos seguimos así es que como
sabemos que esta es una serie geométrica
la suma total sabemos que es igual al
primer término
a menos 2 / 1 - la razón común que es
justo lo que tenemos por acá así es que
sabemos que esta igualdad es cierta
ahora estos son los valores de x para
los cuales esta serie converge pero
bueno ya que nos sentimos cómodos con
esta primera afirmación ahora sí vamos a
la pregunta que nos están haciendo lo
que queremos es encontrar la función que
corresponde a esta serie aquí lo que mi
instinto me dice es que lo primero que
tengo que hacer es pensar en cómo se
relacionan estas dos series así es que
veamos término por término aquí tenemos
menos 2x y aquí tenemos menos 2 luego
tenemos un menos 4 x y un menos 2 x al
cuadrado y aquí podemos empezar a pensar
que esta serie es la anti derivada de la
primera serie que nos dieron o bueno
también podríamos decirlo como que la
primera serie que nos dieron es la
derivada de la segunda serie que nos
dieron a ver cuál es la derivada de
menos 2x pues es menos 2 y cuál es la
derivada de menos 2x al cuadrado pues es
menos 4x y así nos podemos seguir
entonces ya esta función le llamáramos
gdx que bueno mejor vamos a ponerlo así
esta serie es la función g de x
para obtener hdx a partir de la primera
serie que nos dieron lo único que
tenemos que hacer es integrar tomar la
anti derivada entonces lo que podemos
hacer es tomar la integral indefinida de
los dos lados del igual aquí tomamos la
integral indefinida del lado izquierdo y
la integral indefinida del lado derecho
de este lado ya sabemos que vamos a
obtener g de x pero a ver déjame lo
escribo de esta otra forma por aquí
tenemos la integral en el denominador
tenemos 1 menos 2 x y en el numerador
tenemos menos 2 y estamos integrando con
respecto a x pero esto también lo
podemos escribir de esta otra forma así
y esto es igual a la anti derivada de
esta serie pero
la anti derivada de esta serie es la
segunda serie que nos dieron a la que le
estamos llamando la función g de x así
es que la clave aquí es encontrar esta
integral esta anti derivada y tal vez tú
ahorita reconoces inmediatamente cuál es
esta integral porque lo que tenemos aquí
en el denominador su derivada es justo
el numerador si consideramos que ésta es
su si decimos que es igual a 1 - 2x aquí
simplemente vamos a hacer una
sustitución con entonces d
la derivada de eeuu con respecto a x de
y es menos dos menos dos de x así es que
tengo veo aquí en el numerador y podemos
reescribir esto con el cambio de
variable lo que tenemos es la integral
de d
entre iu y esta integral que es esta
tiene que ser igual a g de x y ya
conocemos esta integral es el logaritmo
natural del valor absoluto de eeuu y
como es una integral tenemos que sumar
la constante de integración y esta
integral es igual a g de x y ahora sí
podemos volver a hacer la sustitución de
v porque queremos que todo esté en
términos de x y/o es uno menos 2x así es
que esto es el logaritmo natural del
valor absoluto de 1 - 2x más esta
constante es igual a g de x y ahora lo
único que nos falta es encontrar esta
constante y para hacer eso podemos
evaluar esta ecuación cuando x es igual
a cero entonces vamos a escribirlo por
acá cuando x es igual a cero
esto es el logaritmo natural de
más la constante tiene que ser igual a g
de 0 pero cuánto es g de 0 a ver cuánto
es que de cero cuando x es igual a cero
cada uno de estos términos es igual a 0
g de 0 es 0 entonces esto es igual a 0
pero a ver el logaritmo natural de 1
también es igual a 0 entonces se tiene
que ser igual a 0 y listo ya encontramos
ag x lo único que tuvimos que hacer es
encontrar la anti derivada de ambos
lados de esta ecuación integrando
sacando la anti derivada llegamos a esta
ecuación y después evaluando la ecuación
cuando x es igual a 0 encontramos que
esta constante es cero y entonces
sabemos que gdx es igual al logaritmo
natural del valor absoluto de 1 - 2x
es igual al logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de uno menos 2x ahora por otro
lado si mantenemos esta restricción de
que x tiene que estar en este intervalo
entonces 1 menos 2 x siempre es un valor
positivo y entonces no necesitamos estos
símbolos del valor absoluto porque esto
es positivo pero tampoco tenemos ningún
problema en seguirlo escribiendo en fin
ya terminamos utilizando la expresión
que nos dieron
encontramos cuál es la función
correspondiente a esta serie y lo
importante aquí lo que hicimos para
lograr resolver este ejercicio fue
darnos cuenta que la primera serie que
nos dieron es la derivada de la segunda
serie y entonces inmediatamente esta
otra parte también es la derivada de
esta serie y con esta expresión pudimos
encontrar esta función lo único que
hicimos fue tomar la anti derivada de
ambos lados de esta ecuación tomamos la
integral